marketing for the now the marketing for
the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
hey everybody i'm andrea sullivan cmo of
vaynerx and welcome to vaynerx presents
marketing for the now we're officially
kicking off our summer series
so we've got a new format we're cutting
it back to one hour
there's still 10 minute conversations
with ceos
founders and cmos across a ton of
different industries
some of our interviews are going to be
led by gary as well as
some are going to be led by vaynerx
leaders
today we actually have a bonus guest uh
which is
aj's brother so if you can stick around
from 1
30 to 1 40 to close out the show
today's question is what are your
predictions
for the rest of 2021
marketing for the now and let's get
started
first up we have the amazing jerry
davard
who is a serial cmo and the founder of
black executive cmo alliance
which she will tell us all about jerry
will be interviewed by patrick bennett
creative director at vaynermedia
welcome jerry and patrick
thank you andrea hi patrick
hi jerry thank you so much we're kicking
it off we're number one
i know that's a pressure right i i think
i think we can handle it i think we can
handle it so i mean
that was a very brief look at your cv
but i mean besides
uh founding the black executive cmo
alliance i mean you've also been a cmo
at like office depot
adt citibank you've had leadership
positions at revlon
nfl general mills all these places
you've been named like
one of the 75 most powerful blacks in
corporate america which is just
what a title you know
uh but we met actually nearly 20 years
ago when i was just
a young creative uh working on the
verizon account
but a very smart young creative and
still a young creative right
i mean i'm getting up there you know you
gotta shave to keep the grays away
yeah no i all of that is always very
interesting and some people live on that
that just happens to be what i've done
it's not kind of who i am
i think i've learned a lot a lot of
companies like most marketers
we've worked in a lot of organizations
and so we can kind of figure out you
know solutions from a 180 degree angle
there's not one
way to solve anything and that's what
i've learned in all the industries and
sectors and countries that i've lived in
um to work in this amazing profession
that i love
i love it i love it so you know getting
right into it why
why now you've been in this industry for
a number of
years you've done some incredible stuff
why is now
the time for becca now it's
the time it comes down to if not now
when
and if not me who it really was it came
out of a desire
of wanting to make sure that people
understood
the breadth and the depth of the black
marketers that were out there today
because i got really tired of seeing all
these roundups of the best
of and the leading and the most and
they're not being people that looked
like me
and sometimes people pose this as a
supply problem but it's really a demand
problem
and wanting to open up the scope of what
you saw
as a successful marketer and what
young marketing professionals were
looking at to see does anybody look like
me
to let them know that they could be that
and that they had what they needed
in order to be successful and i wanted
to corral a group of
amazing cmos because i knew
that their mission was to pay it forward
was to give back
and i wanted to do it at scale because
everyone was doing it individually i'm
mentoring two or three people i'm
talking to five or ten people
but how do you do that at scale so that
we can have
impact and i see your cute son oh
look at that we have a guest hey buddy
i think your mom's over there
keep going over there speaking of like
seeing
thank you speaking of like seeing people
like i was lucky enough to be able to
see you
right in this uh you know leadership
role at verizon
20 years ago and that you know we don't
know but that could have completely
changed my trajectory
you know it wasn't until years later i
was working at at digita
as a as a group grave director did i
ever see another
creative director at my level that was
that was black that was mark williams
who went on to
work at chase and a number of other
great places
so you know when you think about just
that simple act of existing
that's pretty powerful it you know what
patrick you're so right and we
underplayed that because what happens is
that when we're in these jobs we're
putting kind of one foot in front of the
other
and trying to keep on top of everything
we're doing or need to do
we don't think about who's looking at us
who's watching us
who you're inspiring until you get those
notes i'm sure you've gotten them we all
get them that says you know when i was
uh
i saw you and i realized that i could
you know a lot of and a lot of times you
can't be what you can't see
because you start to say well wait a
minute if no one looks like me
does that mean that i can't because it's
not a level playing field we know that
we all don't start at the same
you know starting line sometimes we
start back there and you have to catch
up and when you catch up
you have to a lot of times people feel
that they have to be flawless that they
their execution has to be perfect and
the thing that i've done
is shared all the stupid mistakes that
i've made
the landmines that i stepped on so that
hey you know yes you have to be damn
good at what you do you have to show up
and have
solutions but you can overcome adversity
you can come back
from having tripped it's not falling
down it's the getting back up
i love it i love it so you know you talk
a lot about eight people
sorry you have 28 members of the black
executive cmo alliance
that can also share those experience so
you know that's not a one-off
right exactly exactly you know i love
how you talk about meaningful corporate
diversity
and and what that means in an
organization
i mean the talk of today is the next six
months right
um you know it number one i think we can
both agree that this should really be
a top priority for you know any
marketing organization
anywhere am i right i think we can agree
on that
it should absolutely be a top priority
and so okay let me let you finish
well i was gonna say and so you know as
we consider like
making a difference and making a dent
and towards getting towards meaningful
corporate diversity like
let's help people out like what are some
tangible ways or tangible steps
some organizations can take before 2022
to make a difference so it's not even
2022 it's how about making a difference
today
and yeah i'm glad i you know let you
finish i felt like kanye i'll let you
finish
uh but uh it really is
not only should it be a party because
there's a lot of rhetoric after
the murder of george floyd there were
companies that came out
with you know grand protestations around
what they were going to do at last count
there was 60 billion dollars that was
pledged
toward deni initiatives as a result of
companies
recognizing that they needed to do more
all right so that's rhetoric those are
hashtags those are
you know proclamations but but what have
you done
and i think that more and more employees
are starting to hold
organizations accountable for their
words and so you've pledged that
but where are you on the commitments
that you made and more importantly
than what you said and where you are is
what are the consequences
much like any executive or any marketer
does not have the opportunity to stick
around
you know quarter after quarter year
after year if they don't meet their
numbers if they don't meet their
objectives
then if you've stated that you want to
have significant improvement
in representation in support and
development
in retention then how are you doing and
what are you doing
in order to make your objectives some of
this is
evolutionary but most of it is
revolutionary in that you have to be
very
intent about creating change and
understanding where the barriers are
and not allowing them to continue so
what we have to do is ask the question
what did we say where are we and more
importantly what am i doing about it you
know too many times we say
somebody ought to it's like what am i
doing what does my
direct report team look like do i have
any people of color do you have any
blacks reporting to me
am i mentoring any people of color
students of color
leaders of color am i asking my
organization
to be accountable for where we spend our
money and how we spend it
it's those kinds of questions that you
have to ask the organization
but more importantly you have to ask
yourself and decide that you're going to
be the change
that needs to you know lead for others
and i love it you know at the beginning
there you touched on something that i
think is like
incredibly powerful i think a lot of
organizations have been dinged
by padding their diversity numbers
by bringing in the most junior people
while the
you know the top echelons remain you
know as they were
but you were just putting the power in
the hands
of everybody you know whether you're on
the c-suite whether you're you know
somewhere in the middle or
whether you're entry level uh if this is
important to you you can hold your
organization accountable
if there's one thing i would say that
people can do is to
ask the question where what did we say
and where are we on what we said we were
going to do
and is that enough what more can i do by
showing up
by advocating by being an ally by
supporting
by calling it out you know so many times
we see things that need to change but
we're we are
in fear and i'm finding that more and
more people are willing
and interested in having the
conversation about what they can do
so you can start by saying what have we
done what do we need to do and here's
what i think we can do
so everyone everyone has a piece in this
in this
uh solving it because it's not easy but
it has to start with caring and it has
to start with your personal commitment
and also you know just really being very
honest
diversity audits are really important
where are you on the numbers nothing
stops the conversation
like data i love it you know i could
i could really talk to you all day i
wish this was like an hour where we
could hang out
but you know i got to tell everybody
watch the black
executive cmo alliance watch becca you
know whether you
uh want to know how to impact your
organization whether you want to take
part in some of your education
opportunities or some of your uplift
opportunities or some of the
find out ways to pay it forward that is
the place to be
uh jerry thank you so much for joining
us on marketing for the now
and and for joining us uh with such an
important message
thank you patrick they can check us out
at black exec
dot com i love it
thank you jerry thank you patrick
fantastic what you're building thank you
next up we welcome cammy and zubine cami
dunaway is the cmo of duolingo the
world's most popular language learning
app
cami is also an author she has an amazon
bestseller
fit matters how to love your job outside
of work you'll find cami in her vintage
1967 kenskill camper trailer
uh cammie will be interviewed today by
by our very own
zubin molavi president of vayner
commerce
welcome to you both thanks andrea
thanks for joining us cammy great thanks
zubin excited to be here absolutely i
also want to thank
jerry and patrick that was uh riveting i
uh like patrick wish that went on for an
hour as well i hope that uh
we can make that happen cami thank you
again for joining us uh why don't we
start with giving us a background uh
about your illustrious career and why
you joined duolingo
sure so i have been fortunate to work
for some great brands
i led doritos and cheetos i was at yahoo
for a while
when it was really a fun great place to
be
i was at nintendo as head of sales and
marketing so
one of the the common themes for me has
been i like to help
accelerate growth with brands that
already are in a point of strength than
that have a product
market fit that really resonates with
consumers and
that's certainly the case at duolingo
they grew to be the most popular
language learning app in the world with
actually no marketing just completely
organically
and i think it's because we've created a
really special product
that is perfect for digital generation
it's gamified to keep you motivated
it uses ai to make the experience very
personal
and it's also very mission oriented as a
company we
we really believe in free access to
language learning as a way to
just help people advance and so
you know it's a kind of a dream gig to
build a marketing group on top of that
foundation
that's amazing i think i first heard of
duolingo i think it was like in 2011
when um they got a lot of notoriety for
taking and kind of creating meaningful
use out of captcha
and for those of you that don't know
essentially the captcha thing that pops
up
nowadays that goes what's the crosswalk
or pick all the crosswalks or the
motorcycles or whatnot
back in the day it used to be like five
characters or it used to be a
string of sentences or words and
duolingo essentially
took that and what they did is they
allowed people
to translate content and start to build
this machine learning
um environment it was so compelling at
the time of like taking something
that we're using every day and adding
meaningful use to it now we'll get to
that in a bit i think we've got a
interesting topic around that but um
speaking of growth speaking of impact
speaking of changes
so clearly uh with a pandemic going on
uh
people in the workforce across the the
country in the world there were
commonalities they faced
challenges that they faced what are some
of those challenges that you face with
duolingo
that were perhaps unique to duolingo
what was uh what went well for you over
the last 18 months and what can
others that are paying uh that tuning in
right now can learn from
yes so um covid really was a time of
explosive growth for us
in that period when the world health
organization
proclaimed a global pandemic we grew
67 there were
like 30 million new users who came to
duolingo to learn a language and that
surpassed any growth we had seen in the
past even in
big periods like new year's and you know
i think about my own experience
during the pandemic we all wanted
something that we could just feel good
about right
something that we felt like we had some
control over and that
just felt like we were doing something
positive in our life
um you know excuse the phone i guess
that happens
and so you know taking
five ten minutes a day to learn a new
language
is a way of expanding your world and
being able to learn about new cultures
and build new relationships
it was just something that um really
gave people a bright spot
in the pandemic um and
so for my team that meant that
we really had to you know change a lot
of our habits we had to be really
agile we're very global organization
and so we also had to acknowledge that
maybe when there was a moment of
optimism in the u.s
things were still really bleak in brazil
or in india
so really taking time to listen to the
sentiment
of consumers around the world and try
and make sure that
we were tapping in to where the consumer
was at any particular moment
but it it was an exciting time of growth
we love
people learning a language and there are
a lot of people learning a language
during coven yeah absolutely i think the
inability for people to travel
a lot of things like duolingo ended up
giving them that kind of experience if
you will that they couldn't have in the
physical world
of being able to i can't travel to
france so why don't i learn french or i
can't travel to spain let's learn
spanish
um and i think it's it's what's
interesting as well is like
there are different sectors clearly that
did remarkably well
during the last 18 months and some that
just incredibly poorly
and the key is understanding how you
take that and now in your case
leverage that as a platform for growth
moving forward
yeah and you know there were a lot of
silver linings
for example one of the things that we
had to pivot on is we started a few
years ago
doing what we call duocon so
bringing our super fans together to just
talk about
all things like language pop culture
technology
and we had planned this big event in
brooklyn in 2020
and had to pivot to online which you
know caused a lot of scrambling and a
lot of sleepless nights
but the silver lining was that we
ended up having over 115 000 people
tuning in to this virtual duocon from
130 countries
and so the reach that we were able to
accomplish
by being virtual rather than physical
just turned out to be a really great
thing and so
you know as we move forward we're going
to be virtual again this year
and probably always keep a virtual
element because it enables us to
involve people who can't get there
physically
absolutely and given the fact that you
have a digital product you have an
online community
it allows them to kind of connect more
meaningfully
uh than without it that's fantastic yeah
i want to kind of switch topics for a
moment and ensure that our audience is
getting
um even further value from this so when
we think about marketing and product
relationship
95 of brands out there product
influences marketing so you've got these
products and then marketing has to do
something
in terms of getting those products in
front of the right people you're in the
five percent
and uh you're in the five percent in
that marketing
has in your organization actually
influenced product which
intuitively speaking is how it should be
done because marketing is the closest to
the consumer they're listening to the
consumer
and they should be able to influence
product roadmap but what i found
remarkable is that your journey
got you from understanding how human and
people's bathroom behaviors
impact their ability to learn a second
language so i'd love for you to leave us
uh that final question tell us how
bathroom behaviors
impact a second language sure so
one of the things we hear from consumers
is i just i want to learn a language but
i don't have enough time
to learn a language but we were doing
some
research and realized that we all spend
an average of 14 minutes a day on the
toilet
and so we thought how do we make people
like get more productive use out of that
time let's help them learn a language
while they're on the toilet
so we actually created duolingo roll
which is toilet paper that comes in
five different languages and just
enables you
to you know learn some quirky phrases
and that uh in that downtime
so it was a ton of fun we became a
trending topic
on twitter we have had thousands of
requests for toilet paper
we put it in weworks in china so
yeah it's uh it's fun to show up in
unexpected places
just like duo our owl absolutely no and
i think that
it's just one further example of how
marketing can influence product in a
meaningful way
and it's not just uh gimmicky if you
will there's actual value that somebody
gets and it's core to your brand it's
core to learning a language
in your down time so i thought it was
remarkable and i'm glad you shared that
story with us
thanks it was a lot of fun for the team
that's awesome cami thank you so much
for joining us it was an absolute
pleasure
great to meet you thanks so much thank
you cami and zubin i love that last one
that was great
next we welcome stephen and claude
stephen sikoler is ceo and founder of
journey
a company committed to helping all
people live happier healthier and less
stressed
lives couldn't we use a little bit of
that and talking with stephen today
is our beloved claude silver
vaynerx's chief heart officer she
fosters a culture of belonging
and is indeed our heartbeat welcome
stephen and claude
hello
i can't hear you claude can other people
hear you
hello hello here we go thank you for
joining us
why today it's my pleasure how are you
i'm great and i just want to thank cami
and jabin that was a great segment
and patrick and jerry i now know all
about bathroom insights and i'll be
thinking about that for sure as we go on
so we're here to talk about journey
and to kick us off can we hear a little
bit about
your journey how did you get here sure
so i started journey in
2015 march of 2015 after
12 years of running a b2b business so i
basically
helped organizations celebrate and
inspire their employees and so i knew
how important it was for people to feel
seen and recognized and it was a few
years before that in 2011 that i went to
sydney australia
to open an office for for that company
and i found
meditation and other mental health
practices originally through buddhism
actually and it was really
transformational for me fast forward a
few years later moved back to new york
sold the company and thought there was a
real opportunity to help people
by bringing them a lot of these ancient
practices in a really simple
approachable secular way and obviously
if the last
six years or especially the last 18
months have taught us anything it's that
having a good solid mental health
practice can be really
uh essential in today's crazy world and
so
started the company with the help of
real experts on the mental health side
on the workplace wellness side
and we help organizations keep their
people
healthy happy engaged and you know
centered
i love it i mean we're all craving human
connection more so than ever as you just
mentioned in the last 18 months and you
know you and i
have known each other now for a bit and
never met in person
and so this connection is real and i
can't wait until we actually can meet in
person
can you walk us through a couple of the
things that journey actually offers like
some of the tangibles in terms
of mental health meditation how does a
person
kind of work with the the app the
program
yeah absolutely so what we set out to do
was build the leading preventative
mental health product so basically the
product that
people will use on a day-to-day
week-to-week basis to keep themselves
mentally and emotionally
fit and balanced and so that includes a
whole host of
tools resources and probably most
importantly support
to navigate both work and life i think
we all know that
what happens at work shows up at home
what happens at home shows up at work
and that's even before the two were you
know so co-mingled the way they
they are now and so we teach a variety
of practices
in a really simple approachable way so
things like breath work meditation
cognitive behavioral therapy positive
psychology neuroscience
um and because our clients range from
very traditional investment banks and
law firms to startups at nonprofits and
charter schools we need to be able to
meet people where they are so make it
really
approachable and delivered in a way that
people can say yes that's for me
um so we have digital products we do
formally on-site things that are now
done virtually through teams and
zoom and things like that but everything
we do is rooted in human connection
so it's about live group learning so we
believe that people learn best
in a group when they have a teacher and
others that they can interact with and
learn from
uh the second sort of core pillar is
peer support the idea that having the
support of
peers colleagues friends makes a big
difference in terms of
being seen and normalizing experiences
and having people deeply
engaged and then the third is proactive
health how do we
encourage inspire nudge people to do
something on a day-to-day basis
to keep themselves mentally and
emotionally fit the same way we
brush our teeth twice a day or take a
certain number of steps
you know to to move our bodies what's
the mental health equivalent of that
you know the word preventative is
something you don't hear a lot unless
you are
you know working on preventing cavities
or preventing you know your arteries
from being clogged so i think
the idea of this is a preventative way
of going about your mental health mental
fitness is phenomenal it's it's just so
it's clutch i think today
you know the topic of today is where are
we going in the back half of 2021 and
i'm wondering if you have any thoughts
you want to share around
human connection wellness uh the world
of mental fitness mental health
sure yeah i have i have a few thoughts
um
so first i think you know we've we
have done really well with these
vaccines in getting them developed super
quick
and pushing them out and so countries
and in particular regions that have high
vaccination rates will continue to grow
and that's exciting and what we're
starting to see is people spend
more money on experiences versus things
i read a stat the other day that
it was the first time i think this this
last month was the first time where
uh restaurant sales surpassed at home
eating for the first time since the
beginning of the pandemic right and so
it's very core to who we are as human
beings to crave
connection and and human experience so
we're going to see things like travel
come roaring back which we're already
starting to see and
um you know the safety precautions are
still in place in different parts of the
country but it's becoming safer and
safer to travel
i think on the on the flip side of
things unfortunately
underserved communities will continue to
struggle um
for a wide variety of reasons so that's
something that i think we as a society
need to address uh but when it comes to
sort of my i hate to call anything my
area of expertise that might be
overstating it but
sort of the world that i that i live in
um you know
people are still working at home
and lives between work and home are kind
of blended
in a way that doesn't create the
boundaries for healthy living
right and so we're seeing companies and
individuals struggle with
burnout people saying you know i need i
need a break
and so hopefully because it's the summer
here in the states because people are
feeling a little bit safer
people will start seeing friends again
visiting family members and having that
real deep authentic connection that's
just core to who we are
so my my hope is that
as the economy grows over the back half
of this year
we'll start seeing people start to feel
healthier
again because of that one component of
their life is
is now starting to get fulfilled you
know that bucket's starting to fill up
again
because so many of us were were alone
for such an extended period of time
yeah i mean we're wired to belong we're
absolutely wired to be in community in
connection with each other and i love
the fact that
journey has that component of support
because we're not supposed to be on this
island in
you know loneliness bill and it's been a
really rough ride for many many many
people i think
uh we know that we know the stats so in
terms of you know
getting in touch with journey to someone
just like log on and
see if they can you know bring this into
their company i mean this is this for me
it sounds like a slam dunk
yeah well i appreciate that um we've
we've been fortunate in that um there's
a lot of
whether it's senior leaders um at the
c-suite
or hr folks who see this and say hey my
company could use more of this
um so people can reach out to me
directly people can find us
online and you know on linkedin on
instagram on facebook on you know all
the places
um but really we we always work to try
to make it very
relevant for that particular audience
because like i mentioned like
we work with harlem children's zone as
is a partner of ours for many years
right they're very different than some
of the law firms like davis polk or
wachtel
or some of the other folks we work with
right and so how do you make it
very personal for people in a way where
they say
yes this is for me it doesn't feel like
it's it's some woo-woo thing or
something built for someone else or oh i
don't need this
um you know because at the end of the
day the truth is we all we all really do
need that
that connection and in our final moments
can you leave us with just
one bit of mindfulness tip something
that we can do
today to just take a minute
yeah i mean i think it's not much more
difficult than just
closing our eyes and just taking like
one big
deep breath in and out
and just having that pause can really
reset re-center allow us to kind of
ground and connect and of course if we
have more time to take
three breaths or five breaths but you
know
we often go from meeting to meeting to
meeting to meeting especially with zoom
right with no break in between to even
go to the bathroom
even just saying you know what i'm just
going to close my eyes
and just take that one breath can be
really
re-centering so a very small tip but
my tip for today thank you so much for
being here and thank you for the tip
it's great seeing you claude thank you
for that breath of fresh air
stephen and claude next we welcome gary
and dylan lissette ceo of utts brands
dylan joined us in 1995 and represents
the
fourth generation of family of a
family-owned business
and he took this 100 year old brand
public
last year we're so excited to have you
dylan
hello hey gary how are you doing i'm
well dylan
nice shirt brother how do you like my
backdrop
i like it i like it i like what i'm
seeing
i like it a whole lot i didn't know how
how blue and orange would clash
but uh i think you look great brother
it's exciting
uh so dylan i think let's get right into
it because these go very very fast uh i
can see everyone
in the chat a lot of utz og fans
love your product um but for what we're
here for
um what are your predictions for the
rest of 2021 what are you seeing
what are you feeling what's emerging
what's declining
and maybe before that 30 45 seconds on
us just to give context for a few people
that won't know
yeah for those who don't know about us
um a hundred year old business
full-line based in pennsylvania but have
grown
regionally into a national company over
the last
100 years we have uh 1.336 billion
dollars of retail sales
per iri and that's uh up uh a ton over
last year um
uh because of covid and because of a lot
of things that we'll talk about i'm sure
today gary and uh
excited to be here with you and excited
to be working with your crew as well
thank you so so to that point uh dylan
uh
what what is and obviously for uh for
everyone's
knowledge dylan uh and utz are working
with vayner x and the sasha group
um anything from a marketing standpoint
or a consumer consumption standpoint
where people are buying the product
what is the biggest kind of like if i
said you know kind of that fun
business talk that you can have over a
cocktail
hey what do you really what are you
really predicting you we're going to see
here the next six months anything stand
out
i mean what i would what i'd definitely
say is that people are coming
out um people are traveling a
small format you know last year was it
was all the small format was closed down
right you you know
think about negative educating educate
everybody on small format
yeah a small format would be like up and
down the street business the bodegas
just think about new york city think
about
august or july of last year was dead
right people were not going to
their office they were not picking up a
sandwich they were not picking up a bag
of chips
they were home or they had fled the city
to some other place and they were
staying
put inside their house so i think that
the number one biggest change that is
going to occur
and is occurring as we speak today is
the fact that people are coming out
that small format the return to the
office
uh maybe it's hybridized maybe it's you
know two three days a week
but that return to the office will
stimulate the small format
we've seen last year where we had a uh
uh literally like a a stretch of 10 12
weeks where that
that channel of business really shut
down uh it's exploding this year so i
think as people get out
as they travel as they enjoy the weather
as they get outside as they start
traveling back to work
as they start vacationing again um that
whole
small format is really lifting and it's
lifting brands like
you know dirty potato chips and zaps
potato chips
that's why i'm wearing the zap shirt
today but it's lifting those uh
brands up very nicely this year so
that's that's a big change for this year
what about on the the marketing front
you know
as an executive navigating all these
years
you know obviously our relationship
speaks to a contemporary point of view
either shift or affirmation what's been
the most interesting thing that you've
seen from a marketing standpoint since
this is marketing for now
whether it's how people interact with
social or television or
outdoor or does anything stand out
yeah i mean the number one thing i i
think that we've seen and especially we
we used to do a lot more sponsorship you
know we used if we had
10 billion dollars to spend on marketing
we used to spend a lot more on
sponsorships
and we're really moving away from that
we're moving directly to digital social
as most people are aware but what we
really
love about that is the fact that it's
connecting
with people and i think it was one of
the last guests stephen at journey said
you know meeting people where they are
and i think that's so important because
it's absolutely right
i think our brand in general has grown
through the
you know 100 years of existence to what
it is today
by meeting people where they are and i
think that social and digital connection
of really being able to connect directly
to somebody
uh in a very particular manner uh that's
not just throwing up a billboard
you know that a hundred thousand people
pass and you know one thousand of them
happen to
you know catch it and and think about it
but really being able to connect
but then create like that um that 360
connection
where we're connecting with them they're
connecting back to us we're connecting
and it and it's going back and forth and
we're doing a lot of you know kind of
cool stuff with that right now
do you feel that you know there's a lot
of mon there's a real mix that watches
this show you have a lot of
entrepreneurs senior executives and then
you have a lot of fortune 500 cmos
ceos i've always felt that from
madison avenue to main street one of the
things that were really
surprising uh is the disconnect
for entrepreneurs that are watching
they'd be surprised how much
big companies or bigger or bigger brands
than their small business really valued
what i what the industry calls reach
right like hey if we run commercials if
we run those billboards
that will work and it's i almost live in
this bizarro world because
for them they blindly believe what's
going on and here is how they see stuff
why for the fellow executives that are
watching
what do you think makes it hard to go
away from a big baseball sponsorship or
running a bunch of television and
getting a lot of grp's or the way that
you know how brands are built or how
procter gamble taught like
there's an institutional 50 years
of how this is done that is getting
disrupted because of the internet
and you know we're 20 years now into the
internet and still
the majority of big companies still want
to go for potential reach
versus what i think we're seeing
together which is really winning on
relevance
which actually then makes people buy
stuff yeah well i think you also have to
make sure that what you're spending if
you're spending a dollar
you have to know that it's working i
mean that's one of the things i think is
that
when you do i mean we would liken this
to say well if we were a
large uh beverage company we could go
spend you know three million dollars on
the con
you know on a commercial and then you
know hope that it it works and and put
it out there
and then roll the dice and it's a dud
and it falls apart i mean you have no
kind of roi that you can say that dollar
worked and it worked here at a 4.2
return or
you know if we went over here it was 5.9
let's go somewhere between the 42 you
know let's adjust
our messaging so i think that that's the
that's the new world i mean it's
it's talking about where you're i just
had the benefit of uh
hosting uh 12 under 17 year olds for a
week
at my house uh last week and we had two
from
two from italy two from spain two from
germany one from bermuda one from
bahamas
these kids these young consumers the
consumer of tomorrow
were on their phone the whole time they
didn't
i don't know if the tv ever turned on so
if you're thinking about
connecting to tomorrow's consumer
you know what's funny that is all often
and anecdote people share i don't think
people realize how many 30 40 50 60 year
olds
are on their phone during commercials
and now with ott how many commercials
are even getting through
yeah yeah yeah anyway so we really like
it yeah please
final thoughts 30 seconds 60 seconds
what should uh
executives entrepreneurs or or leaders
be thinking about for the rest of 2021
anything else pop out
i mean honestly very quickly i i thought
about this a lot it's
it's man people want to get out people
are excited to get out they've got money
in their pocket
they want to they want to reconnect we
had a barbecue yesterday saw somebody
hadn't come out of the house for a year
they are so excited to be out and about
and to engage and to interact
that's how people should be thinking for
the rest of this year i think it's going
to be very positive
uh very exciting time for um for
everyone for all brands
thanks for being on my friend all right
see ya
love the optimism that was awesome next
we welcome
che huang he's the ceo and co-founder of
boxed
a warehouse club delivery service che is
a serial entrepreneur and started boxed
in 2013 in his parents garage
now eight years later the company
delivers anywhere in the united states
and he's going public and you should
know he's
a star wars fan and has a couple of
stories around that gary
he has a better story than that andrea
watch this jay my man great to see you
please tell everybody where you went to
high school
i went to high school uh where gary grew
up as well
edison new jersey at a school named jp
stevens
uh and out of that school there's a
bunch of random entrepreneurs man gary
you know
you know a bunch of them man why don't
you list off do you know a couple of
them to list off for everybody because
everyone's
so everybody before lists maybe one or
two others
i moved in in eighth grade
so i never i mean my whole life i
thought i was going to jp stevens
i already i the way my where i lived in
a townhouse i already knew my path
because i could cut through the back
it was all very exciting and then my
parents moved me to hunterdon county
so i never got my jp stevens experience
but check to your point
i read that article that there was an
article written once
about all those entrepreneurs and you
being one of them wild stuff
yeah so you got uh us here right
you're honorary jp stevens yeah gary i
don't know if they gave you that yet but
i want it uh we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna lobby for that um
uh you know uh the one of the
co-founders and the former ceo of blue
apron
was out of jp as well three out of the
four co-founders of boxed
uh nature box was founded out of jp
stevens um
uh a bunch of uh just a bunch of there's
there's more and more you know yeah wow
yeah it is and even once in a while i
just meet a random entrepreneur who or
someone at a conference just say hey you
know
jp class of xyz and i'm like oh my gosh
i see a lot of people in the comments it
is a good idea move to edison and send
many kids there if you wanted to be
entrepreneurs
jay uh why don't you give one minute on
fox for the
few people that don't know what it is
yeah boxed is an online wholesaler so
we not only are an e-commerce retailer
uh but we are also now an e-commerce
enabler
on our ecommerce retail side we service
both b2c as well as b2b customers
with snacks pantry items everything you
need to run your household
or your office when it comes to pantry
snacks and coffee
on the enablement side we now package up
all that software and hardware that we
built
so all the front end systems inventory
management systems
warehouse management systems even the
physical robots that we engineer and
build
ourselves we now enable other retailers
in the enterprise to use that technology
stack
via the new sas business so that's what
we built uh basically in almost eight
years from a garage in edison
if i asked you before actually let's go
into it because we don't have a lot of
time
your personal predictions from your
purview of
the rest of 2021 on consumer behavior on
opportunities on marketing strategies on
uh buying friends since during that game
wherever you
make it i i you know and this might be
kind of bold bold talk and maybe
a little bit too much but i
fundamentally believe from what i've
seen
that we are going into the most prolific
back to school
back to work period in not modern
american history but american history
i think we've never had this many folks
not in the office you've never had this
many americans
not in school and everyone is going back
around labor day
maybe not five days a week but certainly
some days of the week
and that is going to create huge huge
huge probably opportunities as well as
supply chain challenges as well so i i
fundamentally believe that's coming up
in
90 short days on that prediction for the
rest of year
do you feel as though um people are
going to go into a mixed environment
do you think that that we have crossed
the chasm of the five day a week
commute is that your intuition or do you
think
we're gonna it's like one of those
things you know like is this gonna be a
moment
that looks like you know how when you're
driving and a cop cars lights go on
and you're scared shitless and you grab
your boat you know if it's the first
time you've
driven with both hands and then the car
goes by and you're like so
relieved but for the first like 12
minutes you drive 55 and then somehow
you don't even realize if you're back to
73
do you think that people are saying it
but we'll find ourselves
in april of 2023 close to where we were
or do you think the societies got
comfortable
with meetings on zoom and other
platforms and we're there
i think um uh i think the latter so
meaning that
um i certainly don't think when we go
back to work this september
it's gonna be five days a week
everyone's flying halfway around the
planet just for a one hour
meet and greet i i don't think that's
going to snap back to like the way that
um
that we used to be back in 2019 and
before but certainly i think
a significant portion of it will come
back and this is not me just
being in the pool and just saying hey i
promise you it's not ice cold jump in as
well
um even you know today in the office
we're seeing more and more people come
back and
when people see each other um and hang
out they're all going out uh
for happy hour today it's just a
different atmosphere now i don't think
people are gonna come back again five
days a week
just for that but certainly a few days a
week if you live uh
in and around the office um i think the
other stuff uh
um that you mentioned before about 2023
yeah man like
you know it's no longer an affront if
you have to dial into a meeting
or or zoom so if you're trying to pitch
the biggest client that you potentially
can have
and if you have to zoom in i think
that's going to be acceptable these days
uh
after it's pandemic i think you probably
wouldn't want to do that back in 18 or
19 but
but these days i don't think anyone
would be offended that you don't fly
halfway around the world just to shake
your hand
yeah i think i think let me it's funny
this is an interesting thing
i probably think 25 of my travel
in 2019 would never happen in 2022
if you if i had to throw a number for
you just think because i think i've done
a lot of chicago miami boston for one
meeting
there's just no way there's no way you
you
you have a number of a prediction that
for you
let's just yourself if i said that gut
feeling
so i'm an outlier in the sense that
dude i flew 250 268
000 miles in united in 2019 dude that
was like it's brutal most of it economy
too so
i have the i have the scars uh from that
year
uh and i love united you know uh but
it's just
it's just long flights you know um so
because the first
uh um customer of ours on the sas side
of the house was based in japan
you know i was doing in 2010 i did six
or seven day trips to tokyo
and so i don't think we're going to be
doing day trips to tokyo anymore so at
least my mileage will
will probably cut down by at least half
i'll do a lot of the domestic travel
uh but no more international meetings
just for one handshake
i think that's behind us so but i do
think 25 is a fair number
um potentially if you're an airline cmo
or exec out there i think
what i'm seeing just anecdotally at
least is that
um some of the leisure travel that
revenge travel is is definitely going to
come back and maybe
bolster some of that lack of business
travel in the coming year and years
i assume boxed you know benefited in a
lot of ways by consumer behavior during
covid
anything um anything fun to share with
us here you can share like
funny things people were buying or or or
maybe even more interestingly for
predictions of 2021
anything that has emerged any categories
any
products anything kind of like i'm just
being nerdy now and being selfish
just curious i love this [ __ ] i'm a
retailer at heart so i love this stuff
dude i i mean you know gary we've known
each other for a few years now and i
always joke that i i'm i'm like a toilet
paper salesperson and like
there's always this running joke until
2020 when like you know it
it got real man and it became like the
most popular profession on the face of
the earth and i had
high school friends hit me up it's like
yo we haven't talked in 20 years brother
but like you got some of that toilet
paper
for me uh and i'm like oh my god do you
any sense
why toilet paper was so high i'm still a
little like
please tell me there's a lot of there's
more flex and other things like
most folks think toilet paper is just
you know you have a
table sized machine pumping out toilet
paper modern toilet paper manufacturing
plants and machines
are basically three stories tall and it
takes about 300 million dollars
of capex to build one you need to be by
a fresh water source this is full on
warcraft man you gotta like
be by the water or you you know in order
to build one of these things
and so if you put if if gary and shay
made
our own toilet paper company dude and we
put 300 million dollars in that machine
we are going to crank that thing
28 hours a day 12 days a week so
when when there's a surge in demand it's
not like they're like oh just crank up
excess
capacity there's no extra capacity those
those machines
are running 97 capacity already and to
build another one it's going to take
years and so
there just wasn't that that point but
why are human like i don't know like to
me like i'm not so
like like to me napkins and tissues
and like jumping in the shower like i
don't i feel like people are too bougie
like i i didn't know like i think we've
just become soft like
like leaves like there's options out
there people
there are definitely options out there
and so funny anecdote is that i was so
confident in my ability to procure
toilet paper just given what we do
uh that we actually caught ourselves in
our household without toilet paper uh
and i had to uh uh
i had to scramble and do the the walk of
shame to our fulfillment center and take
one
take a pack off the uh off the shelf and
i saw multiple people in the fc look at
me just like shaking their head i'm like
yo dude
times are tough man i i underestimated
how much we had at home
um but yeah there could have been other
things man and it was a shocker for
for me and us brother continued success
i'm proud of you
all right thanks gary cheers oh that was
too much
you like that i love that one we're too
bougie
for toilet paper right now we got it i'm
supposed to go fully or go fully bougie
and get a bidet
you know like one or the other that's
right
all right our next guest is the
incredible kara golden
she is the ceo and founder of hint and
kara is a super
woman she was named the ey entrepreneur
of the year
and was one of i love this in styles
badass
50 list nice check out her podcast the
kara golden show
and get her book undaunted overcoming
doubts and doubters
welcome kara hi great to see you
great to see you how you been good how
are you good
cara is you know built an amazing
company
most of you who are watching right now
are very aware of hint i
i got to meet kara over a phone call
very early in that journey and was so
impressed with the way they got
distribution for that product
i remember being on a beach or something
and here and talking to you
about getting into starbucks and things
of that nature and just it's been really
a joy to watch you build this company
thank you i i remember that call as well
so
why don't you tell why don't you tell
people really quickly because i'm sure
it'll be at least five percent that
don't know the brand
let's start there and then we'll go into
what you're seeing in the streets for
the rest of 2021
so i i have it here in case uh people
are wondering what that
is uh so it's an unsweetened flavored
water that i started
actually 16 years ago for so for people
who are
thinking that there's overnight success
stories i mean
it it takes time to build quality and
great brands and
and i'm really proud of what we've done
and uh
yeah started 16 years ago in addition to
building a great product we've built a
different way of actually going to
market over 50 percent of our
business as direct to consumer um so
when you look at
you know the beverage industry as a
whole uh
there are there are certainly companies
the big soda companies that are selling
on amazon and
and box and and others but having a
direct business and having that direct
relationship with the customer is
something that
we've uh built for the last eight years
um and it's a solid incredible
subscription business that many many
people
are using what um what stood out for you
before we go into what's happening in
2021 there's been a lot of contextual
covert conversations anything anything
stand out from you
did anything catch you off guard was
anything a pleasant surprise
from a consumer behavior standpoint as
far as the pandemic
yeah so at the beginning of the pandemic
it actually right before the pandemic
uh hit i guess the end of 2020 we were
really focused
on automating uh a lot of our plants
and so uh most people in the beverage
industry were like
why are you doing that by the way i
didn't come from the beverage industry i
came from the tech industry and
my husband is our chief operating
officer and he also came from the tech
industry
so we kept thinking about well what if
somebody
sneezes on the line right as we're
filling a bottle we don't have
preservatives in the product
what happens so we wanted to get the
people out of the room we've been
working on this for four years to get
the people out of the room by
the end of 20 or sorry by the end of
2019
we had everybody out of the room and
automated and
got got you know those people
away from where the actual phil was by
the time the pandemic hit
we learned that as an essential product
in a pandemic
you have to be running your plants 24
hours a day
you have to uh you know do your best
practices
to best efforts to actually supply
the store shelves so people were
hoarding toilet paper but they were also
hoarding
water bottle water and products like
hint so being able to actually
run our facility without any hiccups
because we
we had planned it out was a tremendous
tremendous advantage in addition to that
we do everything here in the u.s so
we've always believed that
get things as local as possible we
uh blow our own bottles on the lines
where
everything was was has been done in the
u.s so when the pandemic hit
we got a phone call from costco
and they said hey do you guys do
everything local because we're having a
lot of problems
with suppliers that are supposed to be
getting cans from china and they're not
coming
so can we put you guys nationwide with
cos costco
so in addition to going nationwide at
the beginning of
uh 2020 with uh walmart and sam's club
and other huge retailers
we went nationwide in april without
extra
because of the localization yeah and
also just because we were
you know automated as well and so one of
my pr
one of my predictions really for you
know
remainder of 2021 and going forward is
supply chain it matters automation
uh localization and you know pretend
that there's another pandemic coming
because the more that you can rely on
or i should say the more you can rely
less
on people being in the room
that is where you protect yourself
and your company what about from a
marketing
or just what consumers are doing with
products or consumption of media or
marketing
where do you what are you seeing what
are you what are you kind of predicting
over the rest of this year maybe into
2022
yeah so for as you know for years i've
been uh telling people
you know drink water not sugar and uh
and get the sweeteners out of your life
and health is really important
and lots of people listen but there were
some people where it went in one ear and
out the other and they just did whatever
they wanted today
i think if anything great came out of
the pandemic it's that
people want to stay healthy nobody wants
this virus
if they got the virus they don't want it
again and they want to protect
themselves in any way that they can
and so health and wellness as a category
is it accelerated but it's here to stay
and it's just going to get bigger and
what i'm most excited about
is watching companies that are going to
be developed
out of how do we help people stay
healthier obviously we've seen pro
companies like hint and pelleting and
you know lots of other
segments of of that but i think it's
just going to increase and i think
consumers
are listening now and they want it and i
think it's
so important and i think also the direct
consumer with
the direct relationship with the
consumer so i think e-commerce
uh is uh is here to stay and i think
we're gonna see
companies that have not really embraced
it
because they think well you know there's
still these relationships with stores
we've got them we've got lots of space
but another pandemic comes you start to
you know
shut down fast food restaurants
universities
you know you start to see that wow what
happens
what can i do to protect myself having
that direct
relationship with the consumer has
become more
and more important i mean even pre
pandemic just having the actual data
when you're a big brand and you're
selling your product through albertsons
or krogers or
ebj's or costco or walmart you don't
actually know who's buying it
totally and that's the thing too i mean
the other thing that we've seen gary
is that the consumer that is going
online and buying our
bro buying hint from us or from amazon
they'll also walk through a costco store
and they may not go there every week but
they may go there every month
and they see you know a variety pack
that they can't buy from us online and
they're going to pick it up
right and so our sales our direct to
consumer business
tripled in the last 17 months
our uh overall business grew by over 50
50 so it's it's crazy
what's going on but i think it also
speaks to
another trend that i think is really
really important which is
that the consumer is really looking for
authentic brands to guide them and so
you know i know you love talking about
storytelling i'm a huge believer in that
as well
but it's also about how to lead
consumers so
for example we started our company with
hint water
and a few years ago i had a scare with
skin cancer
and i came out with a sunscreen
the number of brands are the number of
soda brands that were saying what is
that tech executive doing
you know she's coming out with the
sunscreen brand that was
never my purpose my purpose was to
service the customer and help customers
understand
that here's a great product we never
even stuck it on the beaches
anywhere to sample it we just said hey
you like hint water come and try this
hint sunscreen
we had like an 80 return on on
you know just an email that went out to
these consumers because they trust
the some brand i believe in that
i'm gonna i'm a big fan of horizontal
expansion for brands i think a lot of
brands have a lot of
permission to go into other categories
and haven't gone there and that's a
little bit of a prediction for the next
decade
continued success great to see you thank
you
thanks kara so gary we've got one bonus
guest today and it's your brother i'm
very excited
i've heard is the co-founder of
vaynermedia and vaynersports now let you
guys take it away
that was it that's all you got for him
that you just like it was just such a
powerful statement you didn't need
anything else
exactly hey bro
how are you um
let's just get right into it you know i
think a lot of people are probably
excited about this i see the
comments exploding um what are your
predictions i mean obviously you've been
spending a time with nfts
but obviously you're spending a ton of
time in the sports business so
with this broad question what are your
predictions for the rest of the year
what's
what's on your mind i should have
probably thought about this a little bit
more
um well yeah you know i'll keep it close
to home nfts
um in general obviously you and i have
spent a ton of time on it this year
um it's it's funny you know i think the
media there's
certain subs in the media that wants to
play this narrative the nfts are dead
i think that's the first thing from the
case i think you have a lot of brands
that
just a month ago decided that they're
going to take it seriously i think i saw
something like fox
invested 100 million dollars to stand up
a division that's going to focus on
their ip and nft so
i think nfts will continue to expand i
think that
everybody that's developing for nfts
from like a picks and shovels
perspective
knows that there's friction that needs
to be reduced everybody knows that you
know
fiat purchasing ability is gonna be a
big deal and
you know even things that are like l2
like matic they're too hard for the
everyday consumer so i think
we're going to see more on that front so
that's fun um i think another thing
that's really relevant to my world
in addition of teas given the sports
agent route is just name image and
likeness
we're two weeks away um we still have so
why don't you break down that for
everybody who's watching what that means
yeah so
name image and likeness in regards to
collegiate sports is the idea that for
the first time
college athletes will have the ability
to monetize their personal brands
um you know the ncaa has made that
not okay they've threatened you know
eligibility
for anybody that tried to make money
there was actually a kicker
who's making good money on youtube
remember i forgot about it
down in florida in florida yeah faq or
fiu one of those smaller florida-based
schools
and he actually just like well cool like
i don't think i'm gonna make the nfl and
the ncaa says
um i'm not allowed to make money then i
guess i'm not gonna play football
anymore and so he kept making money and
he's built the brand as an influencer
and he's done well
i think made the right decision and i
just think that's terrible that he had
to make that decision
um you have all these other industries
right you musicians
there's plenty of musicians that were
attending school and making money on
spotify and youtube and
touring and they weren't stopped so
that's exciting we've got a few states
that are going to go live
it's still a complicated issue there's
still things that can happen from a
federal government
and ncaa perspective over these next few
weeks but
we're inching towards progress and so
that's gonna be fun i think it's gonna
create a lot of buzz
um and i think it's something that's
long overdue so that's gonna be a fun
part of the second half of 2021 as well
what do um you glazed well you you spoke
on it
where would you put nft culture at the
macro consumer level like how early are
we are we in the first inning second
inning third inning
i'll say we're in the second inning um i
give nba top shot a lot of credit
for getting us from the first to the
second i uh
i always have i have a good group of
friends that are not
knee deep into technology and they're
always my litmus right even back in the
day gear like when we did
like things like uber and venmo i would
literally introduce
uber and venmo to my friend group right
and it was always really interesting for
me to see the reactions and
i would look for you know their pros and
their cons and latch onto certain things
and uh i think about the venmo meeting a
lot we were so
[ __ ] early and so were they they
didn't even have a product
in my remember
we nailed that investment and it and
they sold the company fairly early
before it went bananas
yeah no that was as early as it gets
yeah i mean when we invested in venmo it
was sms
only at that point so it was uh you know
you could text money to one another and
there was
a slew of verifications and there was no
it kind of reminds me of like the nft
stuff you're talking about right now
because we're so early like it's
as a matter of fact it was funny i was
going to hit you up off this show but
i'll just do it right now
like i'm going to do like a white glove
concierge i have like four emails on
this flight
from people like hey i have a hundred
thousand dollars i want to buy and be
friends
i've i'm scared shitless i have no idea
and i was like [ __ ] it
nick dio tyler like i'm gonna get the
whole band together send out a bunch of
content next week and be like if you're
a baller we didn't win the lunch
i i white gloved like 15 people into the
experience dio did too like that's what
we did around the launch and it's still
a need
like you said it's not easy it's not
intuitive it's scary
you read the headlines of stealing and
scams and fishing and
the problem is that stuff exists like
the people that are in crypto are some
of the smartest people in the world
and they're unfortunately some small
subset of that population is taking
advantage of people right and so
um it's so early a good example
is you know the most important thing in
the world when it comes to your wallet
is your seed phrase and it's so early
that i think actually seed phrase is
kind of going under a rebrand right now
right there's a great article
about pivoting it to secret phrase so
that people know that it's supposed to
be a secret you're not supposed to share
your seed phrase but what the hell is a
seed phrase nobody knows what a seed
phrase is so
it's that early that like the main
components of crypto and nfts
i still think are a work in progress um
i think it's a big deal
so i think i mean i helped us get from
the first to the second inning
um you know they used a big ip like the
nba you could buy
via credit card that was a big deal um
i'm getting i'm getting i'm sorry good
no no no i'm good
we only have four minutes i'm getting
bombarded uh everybody wants to know
what your favorite b
friend is my favorite v friend um
is my favorite investment is the very
very very lucky black cat
i own a core um of a very rare and an
epic
of that so i'm making a bet that maybe
the cat can be a pikachu
type character it's the only one in the
logo so from a pure investment
perspective that one
from a pure just for fun because i like
the product and everything
and i think you probably know this um
i'm a big fan of the stunned
sun that's because the stun sun for me
is like such an inside joke right like
stunned is a word
that you and i always use growing up
amongst like our closest friends and
stuff like that
just like a word you know i think like
super is a big word for me and you
stunned is a big word for you and i so
like that i like and then the sun
character itself is a real throwback to
your old school old school doodles like
it's half
sun half like classic gary doodle
character
um so that one just resonates for me i
don't think that's gonna be a lot of
people's favorites that's just highly
personal
now i'm just having fun were you
completely blown away by how the hawks
came back yesterday that was
ridiculous yeah i mean i didn't watch
the game so i kind of caught it as a
post game
um what were they down 26 in the third
it's insane late third
like three minutes left on the road game
five
if we're talking basketball i want to
give a shout out to a guy that i think
i've always been higher on than
most everybody and he catches a ton of
[ __ ]
and i don't think he got nearly enough
love for last night's paul george
i think paul george is an incredible
basketball player
he got he's had some bad playoff
performances
um but i mean kawhi goes down
that's a huge w huge game for paul
george in a game five in my opinion
what about the suns fan who beat the
[ __ ] out of those two i love that guy
you want to hear the best part of
defense so he wasn't like comfortable
complete self defense and the fact that
he
had like the wherewithal to cap the beat
down
with the prediction of sons and four and
then it delivered
iconic i'm all in on that guy
as you know like we always get so pumped
when like
athletes or rappers or people we think
are cool are following me on instagram
so it was go on display i was going
through it and i found his instagram
account like somebody tagged him
he follows me i'm so fired up we have to
connect
what do we do where are we going i got
to think of something we got to come up
with
i i'm sorry
had him on the pod already i think i
might put him in a super bowl commercial
i love it i might create a new v friend
just that beats up people like what
we're gonna do like fighting fan falcon
i take a picture with him where you're
doing the five and he's doing and he's
doing the four and that's good
that would kill you just need to pull in
new york for that picture alone i feel
like that's a big one
maybe we'll if it looks i feel like the
sun's gonna be in the finals maybe you
and i will fly out to
a game and bring him take a let us leave
nate behind
no we got to take nate i'm happy for him
i'm sad for us are you ready for
football
beyond ready for football i'm so excited
for the jets
it's uh it's a fresh slate to a certain
extent
it's yeah um they've cleaned up a lot of
the [ __ ] that joe inherited and so we'll
see what they do
up to them thanks for being on everybody
thank you so much for watching marketing
for now
love you bro talk to you later thank you
for watching uh this episode
andrea take us home that was so epic i
love that thanks for letting us
get a little view in on you got a smart
little brother
indeed all right thanks gary thanks
everybody for joining us
next up in july we've got two shows
we've got one on july 6th
marketing for the now apac from 8 30 to
9 30 pm
eastern gary where are you going to be
for that one probably home i'm excited
for netflix
when is it when is it it's on july 6th
so just after that july 4th weekend
and then we've got another one on july
22nd from noon to 1.
so come check us out continue let's
continue the dialogue on
marketing for the now and check us out
on our password for
past recordings on mftn
marketing for the now vaynerx.com and
we'd love to hear from you
thanks everybody bye everyone